It's that time of year when drugstore candy aisles fill with red hearts, the price of a dozen roses seems to skyrocket, and people's thoughts turn to the state of their romantic relationship or their lack of one. For psychologists, romance, attraction, and love are not merely the stuff of poetry. They're subjects for scientific study. What are the qualities of a successful relationship? Why do some relationships last and others fail? What do we gain from our relationships and how do we know which ones are we? worth holding on to. These are some of the questions that relationship scientists delve into, and their research can help the rest of us
每年的这个时候，药店的糖果货架上都会摆满红色的心形装饰，一打玫瑰花的价格似乎也飞涨起来，人们开始思考自己的恋爱关系状况，或者思考自己为何处于单身状态。对于心理学家来说，浪漫、吸引力和爱情不仅仅是诗歌的素材，它们也是科学研究的对象。一段成功的关系具备哪些特质？为什么有些关系能长久，而有些却以失败告终？我们从关系中获得了什么？我们如何知道哪些关系值得坚持？这些都是关系科学家深入研究的问题，他们的研究可以帮助我们其他人
as we navigate this area that is so central to our lives. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Gary Lewandowski, a professor of psychology at Monmouth University,
在我们探索这个对生活至关重要的领域时提供指引。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是蒙茅斯大学（Monmouth University）心理学教授加里·莱万多夫斯基（Dr. Gary Lewandowski）博士，
whose research focuses on romantic relationships, self, and identity. He's published more than 50 academic articles and three books on research methods and the science of relationships, including his most recent book, Stronger Than You Think, The Ten Blind Spots That Undermine Your Relationship and How to See Past Them. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Lewandowski. Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with a timely question. By now, many of us have been hunkered down with our partners for almost a year due to the COVID-O-Nodowski.
他的研究专注于浪漫关系、自我和身份认同。他发表了50多篇学术论文，并撰写了三本关于研究方法和关系科学的书，其中包括他最近的著作《比你想象的更强大：破坏你关系的十大盲点以及如何看透它们》（Stronger Than You Think, The Ten Blind Spots That Undermine Your Relationship and How to See Past Them）。感谢您今天参加我们的节目，莱万多夫斯基博士。非常感谢您的邀请。让我们从一个切合时宜的问题开始。到目前为止，由于新冠疫情，我们许多人已经和伴侣居家隔离了近一年。
COVID-19 pandemic. When the pandemic first started, there were a lot of news stories, some joking, some not, about how all of this COVID stress combined with enforced togetherness was going to lead to a spike in the divorce rate or the birth rate. You've actually done some research on how people's relationships are faring during the pandemic. What did you find? Well, it turns out, a lot of those predictions were just wrong. You know, we had a lot of cynical and negative outlooks about relationships and how, you know, the pandemic was going to affect them. But as it turns out, you know, relationships are a lot stronger than we think and relationships have done a lot better than we thought. And in particular, you know, along with colleagues at the Momuth University
新冠疫情。疫情刚开始时，有很多新闻报道，有些是开玩笑的，有些则不是，说所有这些新冠压力加上被迫的朝夕相处，会导致离婚率或出生率激增。您实际上做了一些关于人们在疫情期间关系状况的研究。您发现了什么？嗯，事实证明，很多预测都是错误的。你知道，我们对关系有很多愤世嫉俗和消极的看法，认为疫情会如何影响它们。但事实证明，关系比我们想象的要稳固得多，关系的发展也比我们预想的要好得多。特别是在蒙茅斯大学
polling center, we did a poll early on in the pandemic in May. And when we ask people, you know, how do you think the pandemic is going to affect your relationship? There's a lot of optimism. 51% said that they thought the pandemic was going to make their relationship stronger. And that's completely counterintuitive to what a lot of people thought at the time. Only 1% thought it was going to have gotten worse. 1%? 1%, right? So it's like, one out of 100 thought, you know, this is going to be bad for us.
民意调查中心，我们在疫情早期的五月份进行了一次民意调查。当我们问人们：“你认为疫情会如何影响你的关系？”时，人们表现出了很多乐观情绪。51%的人认为疫情会让他们的关系变得更稳固。这与当时许多人的想法完全相反。只有1%的人认为关系会变差。1%？是的，1%。所以就像是100个人里只有1个人认为这对我们来说会很糟糕。
And 46% thought it was going to be unchanged. And, you know, unchanged is sort of an unexciting thing a lot of times. But in the context of, you know, a global pandemic and all, of the other worldly stress that our relationships have had to endure the past year, no change is a pretty good thing. For those people who do feel like their relationships are suffering right now because of stress due to the pandemic, do you have any research-based advice to guide them? For people that are suffering, I think it's trying to rely on your partner as much as you
46%的人认为关系不会改变。你知道，在很多情况下，“没有改变”听起来可能有些平淡。但在全球疫情以及过去一年我们关系所承受的所有其他世俗压力的背景下，没有改变其实是一件相当不错的事情。对于那些因为疫情压力而感到关系受损的人，您有什么基于研究的建议来指导他们吗？对于那些正在受苦的人，我认为关键在于尽可能多地依赖你的伴侣。
possibly can. I think it's, you know, one of the reasons why relationships have done well is that for many of us, our romantic partner is our best friend. And by having to stay inside for a pandemic, you're basically being forced to spend more quality time with someone who's your best friend, which isn't so bad. And so I think a lot of, you know, people are having some trouble with their relationship. It's more of a matter of, you know, changing your perspective a little bit. You know, there's a famous quote that says a shift in perspective is worth 80 IQ points. And so, you know, shifting your perspective and really just trying to focus in on all the good that is there that perhaps you're a.
我认为，关系之所以发展得不错，原因之一在于对我们许多人来说，浪漫伴侣就是我们最好的朋友。因为疫情不得不待在家里，你基本上被迫与你最好的朋友共度更多高质量的时光，这其实并不坏。所以我认为很多在关系中遇到困难的人，更多的是需要稍微改变一下视角。有一句名言说：“视角的转变价值80个智商点。”所以，转变你的视角，真正尝试去关注那些你可能忽略的、已经存在的美好事物，
we're looking might go a long way to help people, you know, do better during during these troubling times. More generally, what have you and other researchers found are the most important qualities or ingredients that make relationships work? Some research done by Rhonda Balzorini and many colleagues, cleverly titled Love in the time of COVID, found that, you know, COVID has been very stressful for lots of people. But what they found was when one of the partners was very responsive. And so a responsive partner is someone who listens to you.
可能会在很大程度上帮助人们在这些困难时期过得更好。更广泛地说，您和其他研究人员发现，让关系维持下去的最重要品质或要素是什么？由朗达·巴尔佐里尼（Rhonda Balzorini）和许多同事进行的一项研究，巧妙地命名为《新冠时期的爱》（Love in the time of COVID），发现新冠疫情对许多人来说压力很大。但他们发现，当其中一方非常善于回应时——所谓善于回应的伴侣，是指那些倾听你、
cares what you think and tries to see things from your perspective. It really helped mitigate a lot of the stress that COVID has brought on. So being one of those partners who really takes the time to understand, validate and care for each other is really going to help your relationship weather the storm. You did an interesting poll a few years ago where you asked people whether their partner was their best friend, and you found that 83% said yes, a far higher number than in a similar survey 25 years earlier. Why do you think that's changed? I think we're getting better at relationships. I think we're expecting more, and rightfully so.
关心你的想法并试图从你的角度看问题的人——这确实有助于减轻新冠带来的许多压力。因此，成为那种真正花时间去理解、认可和关心彼此的伴侣，真的会帮助你们的关系度过难关。几年前，您做了一项有趣的民意调查，询问人们他们的伴侣是否是他们最好的朋友，结果发现83%的人回答“是”，这个数字远高于25年前的类似调查。您认为为什么会发生这种变化？我认为我们在处理关系方面变得更好了。我认为我们期望更高，这是理所应当的。
Our relationships are one of the most important parts of our life. It's the source of lots of the good times, lots of the bad times. And so compared to 20 years ago, certainly 50 years ago, our expectations are just much higher. And I think by and large, that's a good thing. You know, we not only are looking for someone to help pay the bills and run the household and make just so our day-to-day experience work. I mean, those were more partnerships. Now we're really looking to our partners to help us become better people, give us a more fulfilling and meaningful experience. And, you know, I think largely people are able to find that.
我们的关系是我们生活中最重要的部分之一。它是许多美好时光和许多糟糕时光的来源。因此，与20年前，当然还有50年前相比，我们的期望值要高得多。而且我认为总的来说，这是一件好事。你知道，我们不仅在寻找一个能帮忙付账单、操持家务、让日常生活运转的人——那些更像是合伙关系。现在，我们真正期待伴侣能帮助我们成为更好的人，给我们带来更充实、更有意义的体验。而且，我认为大多数人确实能够找到这一点。
You know, we're waiting longer to get married. So, you know, in some ways, we're making a lot better choices. And, you know, the divorce rate has gone down. So, you know, it's, we're getting better at this, which is really nice to see. I'm going to speculate here because I think there's no data, but I'm wondering if you think the women's movement has had any effect on this because relationships are becoming more egalitarian? Absolutely. Yeah. I mean, I think the best relationships are the ones that are, like you said, egalitarian,
你知道，我们结婚的时间推迟了。所以，在某些方面，我们做出了更好的选择。而且，离婚率也下降了。所以，我们在这方面做得越来越好，这真的很高兴看到。我想在这里推测一下，因为我认为没有相关数据，但我很好奇您是否认为妇女运动对此产生了影响，因为关系正变得越来越平等？绝对是这样。我的意思是，我认为最好的关系就是像您所说的那样，是平等的，
where partners share power and they're equals. And both partners get to be their own person and help each other become better people. And so, you know, when you have an automatic imbalance of power from the start, you know, particularly along male and female gender roles and stereotypes, it's just going to bake in this automatic incongruity and inequity between couples that is just not going to lead to the equality that we know relationships need.
伴侣双方分享权力，地位对等。双方都能做回自己，并帮助对方成为更好的人。所以，当你从一开始就存在自动的权力失衡时，特别是在男性和女性的性别角色和刻板印象方面，这就会在伴侣之间埋下自动的不协调和不平等，这绝不会带来我们所知的关系所需要的平等。
Are there universal warning signs that a relationship is doomed? And if so, what are they? I wish there were, right? I mean, it would make everyone's life so much easier if there were. Yeah, ding, ding, ding, there it is. Yeah, like, there it is. There's the big red flag I need to avoid.
是否存在一段关系注定失败的普遍预警信号？如果有，它们是什么？我希望有，对吧？我的意思是，如果真的有，那会让每个人的生活都轻松得多。是的，叮叮叮，就是那个。是的，就像那样。这就是我需要避免的那个大红旗。
You know, it turns out relationships are complicated. You know, it's between two different individuals. I mean, this is not, you know, not saying anything that people don't know. But we're just not very good at reading signs and knowing what the right signs are to read. And so, you know, if there was any one big sign, I'm not sure we'd even pick up on it, even if we knew about it. you know, relationships are filled with a bunch of doubt. It's just we have limited relationship experience.
你知道，事实证明关系很复杂。这是两个不同个体之间的事。我的意思是，我说的这些大家都知道。但我们并不擅长解读信号，也不知道哪些是正确的解读信号。所以，如果真的有一个大信号，我不确定即使我们知道它，我们是否能察觉到。你知道，关系中充满了怀疑。只是我们的关系经验有限。
And the relationship experience we have is not the same as expertise. And so as much as we've had a few relationships here and there, there's so many more relationships out there for us to learn from. And that's where science comes in. And that's really what I'm trying to do with the book is, you know, there's 350 studies or more in this book. And science has the benefit of relying on a lot more people. One thing you write about in your book is that we're a lot less insightful about our own
而且我们拥有的关系经验并不等同于专业知识。所以，尽管我们有过几次恋爱经历，但还有更多的关系供我们学习。这就是科学的用武之地。这确实是我写这本书想要做的事情，书中有350多项研究。科学的优势在于它依赖于更多的人。您在书中写到的一件事是，我们对自己关系的洞察力远不如我们想象的那样。
relationships than we think we are. You describe a study where college students were less accurate at predicting how long their current relationships would last than their parents or roommates were. Why is that? Is love truly blind? Yeah, it's also a little deaf, a little dumb. Yeah, I mean, that study shows, you know, you ask people, to look off into the future and what's your relationship going to be like.
您描述了一项研究，大学生在预测当前关系能持续多久方面，准确度不如他们的父母或室友。为什么会这样？爱情真的是盲目的吗？是的，它还有点聋，有点哑。我的意思是，那项研究表明，你让人们展望未来，看看他们的关系会是什么样子。
And if you're asking the person who's in the relationship, they're really confident about that answer. It's your relationship. Who knows you and your partner better than you? But what that study shows us is that as much as the person in the relationship is the most confident, they're also the least accurate. You really can't ask for a worse combination than being super confident about really inaccurate information.
如果你问的是身处这段关系中的人，他们对那个答案非常有信心。这是你的关系。谁能比你更了解你和你的伴侣呢？但那项研究向我们表明，尽管身处关系中的人最有信心，但他们也是最不准确的。你真的找不到比“对极其不准确的信息充满信心”更糟糕的组合了。
And really what happens is your parents, You know, it's parents, but it's really mostly moms and your roommate have some other information that you don't necessarily in the sense that they're not in love with your partner. And so when you're in love, you're making decisions for more emotional side. Your roommate knows what you've told them, but also sees some of the fallout perhaps of a bad experience you had with a partner, a fight, or, you know, perhaps crying in your room. those kinds of things. They have that inside information. And so both, particularly your mom and your roommate to a large extent, just want what's best for you. They don't really care about your partner's feelings. And so a lot of times in relationships, we get really wrapped up and convinced that we're doing a lot of things that aren't good for us for our partner. And that's ultimately going to be
实际上发生的情况是，你的父母——你知道，主要是妈妈——和你的室友拥有一些你未必拥有的信息，因为他们并没有爱上你的伴侣。所以当你坠入爱河时，你的决定更多是出于情感层面。你的室友知道你告诉过他们的事情，但也可能看到了你与伴侣糟糕经历的一些后果，比如争吵，或者，你知道，可能在房间里哭泣，诸如此类的事情。他们拥有那些内部信息。因此，无论是你的妈妈还是你的室友，在很大程度上，他们只是想要对你最好的。他们并不真正关心你伴侣的感受。所以很多时候在关系中，我们变得非常投入，并确信我们正在做很多对我们和伴侣并不好的事情。而这最终会
for the good of the relationship, which is actually another, you know, one of the blind spots I talk about in the book. That experiment was with college students. What happens as we get older? Do we get better at this as we gain more wisdom and relationship experience? We do to a large degree. You know, we get a clear sense of who we are. And so when we have a clear sense of who we are, it gives us a better chance to know what we want. And when you're clear about who you are, you can find partners who see you as you see yourself. And that's important because we don't want to form relationships with partners who are only willing to love us if we're willing to just change a little bit. And similarly, we don't want to have to do that to other people as well.
为了关系好，这实际上是另一个我在书中谈到的盲点。那个实验的对象是大学生。随着我们年龄增长会发生什么？随着我们获得更多的智慧和关系经验，我们会变得更好吗？在很大程度上我们会。你知道，我们对自己有了更清晰的认识。所以当我们对自己有清晰的认识时，它让我们更有机会知道自己想要什么。当你清楚自己是谁时，你就能找到那些像你一样看待你的伴侣。这很重要，因为我们不想与那些只有在我们愿意做出一点改变时才愿意爱我们的伴侣建立关系。同样，我们也不想对别人那样做。
And so, you know, as we mature and, you know, focus also in terms of our relationships, more on the friend relationship that we have with our partner rather than the purely physical, arousal, you know, that immediate passionate love types of feelings. You know, we get a little wiser as we age and realize that, you know, being friends is really important. In fact, one of the studies I talk about is a study with what they called expert couples. These are couples who are happily married for over 15 years. And they said, you know, what's the secret? You know, how did you do it? And the number one answer was, my partner is my best friend. The number two answer was, I like them as a person. And so, you know, it's certainly passionate love will get us married, but it's the companion at love
所以，随着我们成熟，并且在关系方面，更多地关注我们与伴侣之间的友谊关系，而不是纯粹的身体上的、唤起的、那种即时的激情之爱，我们会随着年龄的增长变得更聪明，并意识到友谊真的很重要。事实上，我谈到的其中一项研究是对所谓的“专家伴侣”的研究。这些伴侣是幸福婚姻超过15年的夫妻。他们说：“秘诀是什么？你们是怎么做到的？”排名第一的回答是：“我的伴侣是我最好的朋友。”排名第二的回答是：“我喜欢他们这个人。”所以，激情之爱确实能让我们结婚，但正是伴侣之爱
that keeps us married and keeps us happy. So what are some of the blind spots that you talk about in your book? So there's the amount of how much sex you're having and focusing too much on the number of times you're having sex per week, trying to aim for perfection, that, you know, setting your standards where, you know, you're looking for the perfect romantic partner. The idea that men and women in heterosexual relationships are completely different. The idea that, you know, we need to be as close as we possibly can to have a happy relationship, that, you know, closeness is, again, you know, should be taken to the extreme in some ways. One of the myths is that, you know, it's not okay to be a little selfish in your relationship.
让我们保持婚姻，保持幸福。那么您在书中谈到的一些盲点是什么？比如你们性生活的频率，过于关注每周性生活的次数，试图追求完美，设定标准时寻找完美的浪漫伴侣。认为异性恋关系中的男女完全不同。认为我们需要尽可能亲密才能拥有幸福的关系，认为亲密关系在某些方面应该走向极端。其中一个误区是，在关系中表现得稍微自私一点是不可以的。
And in fact, that being a little selfish is a good thing. You know, I mentioned the idea about sacrifice, you know, that we should make all kinds of sacrifices for our partner, things like we shouldn't argue. Things like, you know, my partner must support me in every way at all times. Those are some of the main ones. How do you know when you've over-sacrifice, when you've given up too much of yourself? Yeah, I mean, one of the things I say in the book is that, you know, sacrifices ideally should be mutual and minimal. And so, you know, if you're sacrificing a lot, that's fine, but just make sure your partner is too. And so, you know, you should be maintaining a sense of equity there.
事实上，稍微自私一点是一件好事。你知道，我提到了牺牲的想法，我们应该为伴侣做出各种牺牲，比如我们不应该争吵，比如我的伴侣必须在任何时候以任何方式支持我。这些就是其中一些主要的盲点。你怎么知道自己是否过度牺牲了，是否放弃了太多的自我？是的，我在书中说过的一件事是，牺牲理想情况下应该是相互的且最小化的。所以，如果你牺牲了很多，那没关系，但要确保你的伴侣也一样。所以，你应该在其中保持一种公平感。
They also should be minimal. You shouldn't have to forsake major aspects of yourself and your interests and things that you enjoy for the sake of your relationship. And a lot of times people kind of take on this martyrdom about their relationship where it's like, you know, I'm going to be the one that gives up all of this stuff because they really believe that it's going to help their relationship. And now we know that when you make sacrifices, your commitment does increase, which sounds like a really good thing. And by and large it is, but your commitment increases, but your satisfaction and happiness doesn't. So you're becoming more locked in to a relationship that isn't necessarily making you happier. We also know when you make sacrifices for your partner, it doesn't necessarily increase your partner's commitment. And that seems odd, right?
它们也应该是最小化的。你不应该为了关系而放弃自己的主要方面、兴趣和你享受的事情。很多时候，人们在关系中会产生一种殉道感，觉得“我要成为那个放弃所有这些东西的人”，因为他们真的相信这会帮助他们的关系。现在我们知道，当你做出牺牲时，你的承诺感确实会增加，这听起来是一件非常好的事情。总的来说确实如此，但你的承诺感增加了，而你的满足感和幸福感却没有增加。所以你被锁定在一段并不一定让你更快乐的关系中。我们也知道，当你为伴侣做出牺牲时，这并不一定会增加你伴侣的承诺感。这看起来很奇怪，对吧？
It's like, you know, I'm making these sacrifices because I want my partner. It's helping me buy into the relationship. It should seem like it should help my partner buy in as well. But the problem that you run into is that partners, they don't notice everything that you're doing. In fact, they miss 50% of it. And so if you're making a bunch of sacrifices and your partner can't be bothered to notice, you're really setting up this toxic mixture that you're just going to, you know,
就像，我做出这些牺牲是因为我想要我的伴侣。这有助于我投入到这段关系中。看起来它似乎也应该帮助我的伴侣投入进来。但你遇到的问题是，伴侣并没有注意到你所做的一切。事实上，他们错过了50%。所以如果你做了一堆牺牲，而你的伴侣却懒得去注意，你实际上是在制造一种有毒的混合物，你只会……
start hating your relationship partner more and more rather than, you know, all this sacrifice was supposed to help and it turns out that it's hurting. Hmm. So are you supposed to say, so, honey, did you notice that I vacuum today? I mean, how are you supposed to deal with that? Yeah, you know, it's actually, it's really tricky because, you know, it's this needle you have to thread because as much as you want to make sacrifices, you're right. You should, if you feel like you're really giving that much and your partner's really not noticing it all, it's always good to bring it up.
开始越来越讨厌你的伴侣，而不是像预期的那样，所有的牺牲本应有所帮助，结果却造成了伤害。嗯。所以你应该说：“亲爱的，你注意到我今天吸尘了吗？”我的意思是，你应该如何处理这个问题？是的，这真的很棘手，因为你必须走钢丝。因为尽管你想做出牺牲，你是对的，如果你觉得你付出了那么多，而你的伴侣真的完全没有注意到，那么提出来总是好的。
It's always, you know, be willing to engage in those uncomfortable conversations. That's a good thing. But we also know that when it comes to support, the best kind of support you can offer your relationship partner is invisible support, support that they don't notice. And so, you know, if you're vacuuming and they're not noticing, rather than trying to get credit for all the little things that you're doing, chalking up to invisible support and just know that you're doing things for the benefit of the relationship. And in fact, we do know that when people are making sacrifices and they're doing it for that reason, for the benefit of the relationship, they work out much better than if they think it's
总是愿意进行那些不舒服的对话，这是一件好事。但我们也知道，当谈到支持时，你能提供给伴侣的最好支持是“隐形支持”，即他们没有察觉到的支持。所以，如果你在吸尘而他们没有注意到，与其试图为你所做的所有小事邀功，不如将其归结为隐形支持，只要知道你是在为了关系的利益而做事。事实上，我们确实知道，当人们做出牺牲并且是因为这个原因——为了关系的利益——而做时，它们的效果要比出于义务感或某种责任感而做要好得多。关于冲突呢？我想我们都知道那些总是争吵但在一起很长时间的伴侣。另一方面，有些伴侣几乎从不吵架。那么在一段关系中，多少冲突才算太多？有没有可能冲突太少？是的，我想从最后一点开始说起。冲突太少绝对是存在的。
out of obligation or some sense of duty. What about conflict? I think we all. all know couples who are always bickering, but they've been together for a long time. And on the other hand, there are couples who almost never fight. So how much conflict is too much in a relationship? And is it possible for there to be too little? Yeah, I'm going to start with that last point. You know, there's definitely such a thing as too little conflict.
我认为这是那些更大的盲点之一，我会听到人们说：“我知道我处于一段良好的关系中，因为我们从来没有吵过架。”如果你在一起才一周，那很好，因为在早期你可以不吵架也能过得去。但如果你是两个在关系中平等分享权力的个体，你们会有自己的观点，几乎不可能不经历一些冲突。所以，太多的争吵，也许取决于你们是如何争吵的
I think it's one of those larger blind spots where, you know, I'll hear people say, well, I know I'm in a good relationship because we have never had a fight. And, you know, if you've been together a week, fine. That's great. because early on you can get by without fighting, but if you're two people who share power equally in a relationship, you're going to have your own opinions, it's almost impossible not to experience some conflict. And so too much fighting, perhaps, it depends on how you're fighting
以及你们是如何处理它的。但总的来说，你提到了那些总是争吵的伴侣。争吵是一种强度很低的冲突。这是一个好迹象。因为它意味着当小事情出现时，你们愿意去处理。这让你们能够解决这些小事。正如我在书中所说，让小问题保持在小范围内，避免它们堆积并演变成大规模的全面战争。我在书中称之为“厨房思维”演变成“厨房水槽”，对吧？
and how you're doing it, I think. But by and large, you know, you mentioned those couples that are bickering all the time. Bickering is a very low intensity kind of conflict. And that's a good sign. Because it means that when little things are coming up, you're willing to engage. And that allows you to address these small things. As I say in the book, keep small problems small and avoid them sort of compounding and growing into these large-scale major all-out wars. Something I call in the book, you know, kitchen thinking that turns into kitchen sinking, right?
因为你把整个厨房水槽都扔向了你的伴侣，因为你积攒了所有这些小事，试图让它过去。我想让它过去，随便吧，好吧。然后突然间，它就变成了牙膏盖，对吧？他们没有把盖子盖回去，你就崩溃了。所以你绝对要避免这种情况。那么你怎么知道什么时候真的该离开了？这是一个价值百万美元的问题，真的。
Where you throw the entire kitchen sink at your partner because you've kind of built up all these little things trying to let it. I'm going to let it go. I want to let it go, whatever, okay. And then all of a sudden, it's a cap on a toothpaste, right? And they don't put the cap back on and you just lose it. So you definitely want to avoid that. So how do you know when it's really time to go? It's the million dollar question, really?
我的意思是，人们的关系中充满了怀疑。我在书开头提到的其中一项研究中，他们问那些正在考虑离开一段关系的人：“你在考虑留下时在想什么？”有27个理由。他们问：“你在考虑离开时在想什么？”有23个理由。那些处于这些关系中的人有高于平均水平的留下倾向。但同样这些人，也有高于平均水平的离开倾向。这只是表明决定起来有多难。但是，我最提倡的一点是——这听起来可能有点
I mean, it's, you know, people's relationships are filled with a lot of doubt. You know, one of the studies I start off the book with, they asked people, you know, who are considering leaving a relationship, you know, what are you considering when you're thinking about staying and there were 27 things? And they asked, you know, what are you thinking about when you're thinking about going? There's 23 things. And people who are in these relationships had an above average inclination to stay. The same exact people, though, had an above average inclination to leave. And so it just shows like how hard it is to really decide. But, you know, the thing that I advocate more than anything, and then, you know, this is going to sound a little bit
像是一个逃避的回答——我在演讲中和对我的学生说，更好的数据会带来更好的决策。所以，不会只有一个信号。会有很多信号。你要确保自己正确解读了这些信号。而正确解读这些信号的方法是尽可能充分地了解潜在的信号。实现这一点的途径是通过现有的关系科学。因为过于依赖我们听到的一些轶事，或者代代相传的家庭智慧，可能并不那么明智。当我们谈到关系的终结时，您做过关于分手的研究，并且您有
like a cop-out answer is, you know, I say in talks and to my students that, and all the time, better data leads to better decisions. And so, you know, there's not going to be one sign. There's going to be lots of signs. And you want to make sure you're reading those signs properly. And the way to read those signs properly is to be as well informed about the potential signs as possible. And the way to do that is through the relationship signs that's out there. Because relying too much on, you know, some of the anecdotes we've heard or, you know, family wisdom that's been passed down may not be so wise. As we talk about the end of relationships, you've done research on breakups and you have
一个受欢迎的TED演讲，题目是《为什么分手不必让我们破碎》（Why breakups don't have to leave us broken）。您发现了什么？您说的“分手不必让我们破碎”是什么意思？很多时候，分手是我们喜欢用二元论来思考的经历之一，比如事情要么好要么坏。而且，分手通常被认为是坏事。所以当我还是研究生时，你会审视自己的生活，思考你的生活是如何走过来的，并以此作为产生研究想法的一种方式。
a popular TED talk called why breakups don't have to leave us broken. What did you find? What do you mean that breakups don't have to leave us broken? So a lot of times, you know, breakups one of those experiences where, you know, we like to think in binary terms, like, you know, things are either good or bad. And, you know, breakup is always generally considered to be bad. And so when I was a grad student, I, you know, you kind of look into your own life and think about how your life is gone and use that as a way to create some research ideas.
我在学习分手时心想：“你知道吗？我经历过一些分手。它们实际上相当不错。”比如，当时很艰难，但很快你就会意识到：“哇，离开那段关系是必要的。”所以我开始深入研究它。做了一些研究。而且，我的很多研究都集中在自我上。
And I thought to myself when I was learning about breakup, like, you know what? I've had some breakups. They're actually quite good. Like, you know, they're tough at the time, but very quickly you realize like, wow, that was necessary to get out of that relationship. And so I started looking into it a little bit. Did some research. And, you know, a lot of my research focuses on the self.
发现当你的关系——正如它应该的那样——帮助你成为一个更好的人时，当你失去那段关系，你就失去了自己的一部分。所以那是坏事。那是我的第一项研究，因为我们总是关注负面情绪。这是在观察对自我的负面影响，确实发现了这一点。但我看了硬币的另一面，那就是：如果你的关系并没有帮助你成为一个更好的人呢？那时会发生什么？
and found that, you know, when your relationship, as it should, helps you become a better person, when you lose that relationship, you lose part of yourself. So that's bad. And, you know, so that was the first study I did because, you know, we'd always looked at negative emotions. This was looking at negative impact on the self and definitely found that. But I looked at the flip side of that coin, which was, well, what if your relationship isn't helping you become a better person? What happens then?
结果证明，这是“减法带来的加法”，因为你的关系应该是自我成长的一个主要来源。当你和一个不能帮助你成长的人在一起时，简单地离开那段关系现在就让你自由去追求其他成长的机会。意识到这一点很重要，因为很多人错误地预测了分手会有多糟糕，认为它会比实际情况糟糕得多，
And it turned out that, you know, it was addition by subtraction, that because your relationship should be a main source of self-growth. When you're with somebody who doesn't help you grow, simply getting out of that relationship now frees you up to pursue other opportunities for growth. And it's an important thing to realize because so many people mispredict how bad a breakup is going to be and think it's going to be a lot worse than it is,
这导致他们留在一段关系中的时间比他们应该留下的要长得多。所以，我们真正想确保人们做到的是，知道伟大的关系很少失败，但糟糕的关系确实会失败，而且理应如此。但当那些糟糕的关系失败时，你有机会去寻找每个人都应得的伟大关系。您在“自我扩展理论”（self-expansion theory）方面做了很多工作。您能解释一下那是什么，以及它与关系有何关联吗？绝对可以。
which leads them to stay in something much longer than they should. And so, you know, what we really want to make sure people do is know that great relationships seldom fail, but the bad ones do as they should. But then when those bad relationships fail, you have an opportunity to go find the great relationship that everybody deserves. You've done a lot of work on something called self-expansion theory. Can you explain more what that is and how it relates to relationships? Absolutely.
自我扩展是一个概念，即我们都有一个成长的基本动机，并不断提升自己。我们可以通过许多不同的方式做到这一点，但主要方式之一是通过我们的亲密关系。所以，我们寻找那些帮助我们获得新的、有趣的、具有挑战性体验的伴侣。我们学习新的视角、新的技能，从伴侣那里学习新的爱好，所有这些事情，当我们开始与某人建立关系时，我们开始将他们的特征和经历视为我们自己的。所以我们实际上确实经历了一种自我感的扩展或成长，而我们的关系
Yeah. And so self-expansion is this idea that we all have a fundamental motivation to grow and improve ourselves. And so we can do that through lots of different ways, but one of the primary ways is through our close relationships. And so, you know, we seek out partners who help us have new and interesting and challenging experiences. We learn new perspectives, new skills, pick up new hobbies from our partner, all these things, you know, when we start forming a relationship with somebody, we start taking on their characteristics and experiences as our own. And so we actually literally experience an expansion or a growth of our sense of self and that, you know, our relationship
应该为我们提供这一点。现在，我所做的一些关于不那么阳光面的研究是，如果我们的主要关系不能提供那种自我扩展感，主要的后果之一就是人们更有可能出轨。不仅更有可能出轨，出轨并不是凭空发生的，对吧？有一个升级的过程。他们开始做的事情之一就是更多地关注替代选择。所以这个想法是，自我扩展是一个如此基本的动机，特别是在关系的背景下，如果你在主要关系中没有得到满足，你就会寻找其他能满足这一需求的关系。
should provide that for us. Now, some of the research that I've done on the not so sunny side of things is that if our primary relationship isn't able to provide that sense of self-expansion, one of the major consequences is that people are more likely to cheat. Not only the more likely to cheat, cheating just doesn't happen out of nowhere, right? There's sort of a ramping up process. And one of the things they start doing is paying more attention to alternatives. So the idea is self-expansion is such a fundamental motivation, particularly in the context of relationships that if you're not having that need fulfilled with your primary relationship, you're going to seek other relationships that will fulfill that need.
所以关系和人类一样古老，一直追溯到亚当和夏娃。我们还有什么可看的吗？我们现在不是已经完全搞清楚了吗？天哪，如果我们已经完全搞清楚了，那就意味着关系真的非常非常容易，但事实并非如此。这是一个好问题，就像是，这还能往哪里发展？
So relationships are as old as humans, going all the way back to Adam and Eve. What is there left for us to look at? Don't we have this all figured out by now? Oh, my gosh. if we had it all figured out, it would mean that relationships are really, really easy, which they're not. It's a good question, you know, it's like sort of where can this go?
简单的回答是，无论我们理解了什么，我们总能比现在理解得更好。这真的很有趣，莱万多夫斯基博士。我非常感谢您抽出时间与我们交谈。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或任何您
And, you know, the simple answer is we can always understand whatever we understand better than we already do. This has been really interesting, Dr. Lewandowski. I really appreciate you taking the time to talk to us. Thank you. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or wherever you,
获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 speakingofpsychology，连在一起，@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威尔曼（Lee Weirman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weirman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在收听播客的地方找到我们。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。即speakingofpsychology（全部连在一起）@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weirman制作，我们的音频编辑是Chris Condihan。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。